[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير مشاهدينا
نحييكم الى هذه التغطيه الخاصه بمحاكمات
ترامب لنتابع مختلف تطورات والتفاصيل
والتفسيرات هذا الملف على الداخل الامريكي
وفي عناوين هذه الساعه
محاكمه ترامب بعد اكثر من ساعات او بن
امني وترقب سياسي وانقسام في الراي العام
وتجمع لانصار ترامب منذ الصباح وشرطه
نيويورك تستعد للتعامل مع اي مفاجات
وبعد ان يمثل امام المحكمه ومن فلوريدا
خطاب مرتقبون للرئيس السابق الليله
ونحييكم الى التفاصيل الرابع من ابريل يوم
تاريخي في الولايات المتحده رئيس امريكي
الى المحاكمه نتحدث عن دونالد ترامب
الرئيس الامريكي السابق سيقف بعد قليل
امام قاض صارم كما وصف لمواجهه لائحه
اتهامات لا يعرف نتائجها قضيه شراء صمت
ساعات من الترقب الامريكيون منقسمون وان
التف جلهم حول ترامب ومن فلوريدا خطاب
مرتقب ماذا سيكشف وبماذا سيتحدث ترامبو في
يومه الكبير
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
في هذا المبنى وفي الطابق الخامس عشر
تحديدا سيقف اول رئيس امام قاضي بتهمه
جنائيه بعد ان يستوفي المراحل القانونيه
في كل غرفه ولن يشفى ليديه من الاصفاد غير
منصبه السابق ربما هي جلسه بروتوكوليه
وسيغادر بعدها بكفاله اما بالنسبه للترومب
المحاكمه بكل اركانها مجرد مشهد من حملته
الانتخابيه
صراعه مع العداله سيستمر لابعد من
الانتخابات لكن الاضواء التي سلطت عليها
وضعت اخر اللمسات على دور الضحيه الذي
لبسه منذ ان غادر البيت الابيض
ولا مخلصه لامريكا من بطش الديمقراطيين
غير العوده وهي كافيه لتكون برنامجا
انتخابيا بالمحتوى والعنوان قد لا يحتاج
تروم حتى الان لانزال المحتجين افواجا الى
الشوارع وهو الذي يستعرض شعبيته في كل
تجمع الانتخابي خاصه وان اموالهم تفي
بالغرض
النداء اثمر ثمانيه ملايين دولار جمعتها
التبرعات المخصصه لمواجهه متاعب ترامب في
نيويورك سخاء الانصار وجه اخر للشعبيه
استطلاعات الراي كشف الدعم الجمهوريا
مطلقا غير ان الخصوم اعتبروها زوبعه في
بيت الحزب الجمهوري لا غير
الفوز في الانتخابات العامه يحتاج لكسب
الاصوات المتارجحه لكن الكثير ممن لم
يحسموا امرهم بعد سئموا مما وصفوه بفائض
الدراما والفوضى التي شوهت سوره البلاد
جزء اخر اعتبر مصيرا الرئيس السابق اهانه
لامريكا ويعبر عن تطويع القانون لتصفيه
حسابات سياسيه الاكيد ان تشومب قطع خطوات
في طريق الفوز بالانتخابات التمهيديه بل
احيانا مدفوعا بدعم اقوى المنافسين لكن
النصر الاكبر قد يحتاج تفاصيل اصغر لم
تنكشف بعد
وفي اخر التطورات هذا الملف وصل المداع
العام لمنهات الى محكمه نيويورك قبل ساعات
قليله من بدء محاكمه الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب قبل ذلك قالت ترامب ان لائحه
الاتهام ضد ستشمل 33 تهمه متهما مدعي عاما
بتسريب اللائحه لوسائل الاعلام كما اشار
رئيس الامريكي السابق الى انه لا توجد
تغييرات او مفاجات وانه غير مذنب كما قال
مؤكدا انه يجب توجيه لائحه اتهام الى
المدعي العام نفسه حيث تسربت محتوياته
لوائح الاتهام المعلقه الى الصحافه
ومشاهدينا كما نتابع الان يظهر هذا
الفيديو المسافه التي سيقطعها موكب الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب من برجه في
وسط نيويورك الى قاعه المحكمه في منهات
ويشير الفيديو كما هو محدد مشاهدينا الى
موكبره في المنطقه الخلفيه لبرج ترامب وهو
يستعد ليقل الرئيس السابق الى قاعه
المحكمه اذن ساعه تقريبا او اكثر بقليل
تفصلنا عن وصول ترامب ودخوله الى المحكمه
وفيما بعد تلاوه لائحه الاتهامات التي
يقول ترامب بانه لن تكون هناك بخصوصها
مفاجات وكانت نشرت بعض الاتهامات وضعت في
قالب التسريبات طبعا الى حين نشرها بطريقه
رسميه ونحن سنقف على كل هذه التطورات
وتاثيرات ما يحدث كذلك على الامريكي على
الانتخابات التمهيديه واربعه وعشرين
القادمه على تكاتف حزب الجمهوريين حيث
كانت هناك انقسامات تقريبا اغلب
الجمهوريين يقفون مع ترامب ولكن هناك
اسماء تقليديه قديمه اعلنت وقوفها ضد
ترامب وهناك كذلك اصوات من الديمقراطيين
اعتبروا ما يحدث يمكن ان يضرب الديمقراطيه
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
نقف على تفاصيل مع زملائنا من نيويورك من
امام محكمه منهات مديره مكتب العربيه في
واشنطن ناديه بالبيسي اهلا بك معنا من
الكونجرس ريتا سليمان مراسله العربيه
اهلا بكم زملائي الكرام في هذا اليوم الذي
وصف بالتاريخيه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه واسمحوا لي ان ابدا مع ناديه
ناديه انت الاقرب الينا كلنا
تتواجديه في محيط المحكمه كيف هي الصوره
نتحدث عن تواجد امني وتواجد اعلامي مكثف
كذلك ما تفاصيل
تماما ريم ونحن نترقب هذه اللحظه التي
سيتحرك فيها موكب الرئيس ترامب من ترامب
الى هنا في منطقه امام المحكمه سياتي
بموكب كبير نرى اصطفاف للشرطه الان تزداد
كل نصف ساعه تقريبا عدا على ان كل عدسه
لكاميرا لوسائل الاعلام محليه وعالميه
ترتقد دخول الرئيس انا اريد لو سمحتي بس
ان اسمح للكاميرا ان تتحرك قليلا حتى تري
عدد رجال الشرطه رجال الشرطه العاديين
الاف بي اي رجال الشرطه السريه الذين
يرتدون اللبس المدني الان يقفون امام هذه
المحكمه في منهات وينتظرون وصول الرئيس
ايضا هناك تغطيه اعلاميه قويه جدا
مكثفه لم اراها في الواقع على مدى 20 عاما
في تغطيه لواشنطون وطبعا باقي المدن
الامريكيه الا احيانا في الانتخابات
الامريكيه
ناديه اسمحي لي فقط ان اشير
واعذريني على المقاطعه الان ترامب يخرج من
برجه في نيويورك في طريقه الى المحكمه
ونحن منذ قليل كنا تبعنا الطريق الذي
سيتخذه ترامب من برجه اي من برج تراب
وصولا الى المحكمه اذا ترامب يخرج من برجه
في نيويورك في طريقه الى المحكمه ناديه هل
هناك عمليه تامين كذلك لهذا الخروج وصولا
الى المحكمه كيف ستبدو الصوره ان وردتك
بعض الاخبار في خصوص ذلك
هو اكيد هناك تجديدات امنيه اغلاق لكل
الشوارع على فكره حتى التظاهرات تبعد عن
المحكمه هناك طوق امني وهناك حواجز يعني
على طول امتداد المربع حول محكمه الجنايات
في الهاتف ايضا علمنا قبل قليل بانه
محاميه الرئيس قالوا بان الرئيس ترامب قد
يتحدث قبل بدء المحاكمه
نتابع الان نادي موكب الرئيس السابق ترانس
اسمحي لي فقط هذا موكب رئيسه السابق
دونالد ترامب يتوجه يخرج من برج ترامب
ويتوجه الى المحكمه موكب من عده سيارات
متابعه وحاله تشديد امني كما اشرت منذ
قليل ناديه سيتخذ هذا الطريق كما نتابع
الان على شاشه مشاهدينا هذا الطريق المؤدي
الى محكمه منهات حيث سيمثل امام القاضي
بعد اقل من ساعه من الان ليستمع للائحه
الاتهامات المواجهه له الى كناتها
تماما
هل تسمعينني انت معنا ناديه ونحن نتابع
هذا الموقف موكب ترامب يتحرك الى محكمه
منهات كما نتابع من خلال هذه الصور مباشره
نعم وهذا هو الموكب الذي رايناه بالامس
عندما تحرك الرئيس من مطار رجوانيا
حيث اقام في الطابق 26 على مدى تقريبا 24
ساعه مع محاميه لتكون لديه استراتيجيه
واضحه كيف سيتقدم الى الامام ايضا هناك
معلومات تقول بان الرئيس الان همومه بدات
تزيد وتتثاقل ليس فقط بسبب هذه المحاكمه
التاريخيه لكن ايضا بسبب تحقيقات اخرى قد
تطاله ربما هذا سيشش سيشجع باقي المحققين
على بدء بالفعل محاكمات اخرى وكانت في
جورجيا بالنسبه لمحاوله تغيير نتائج
الانتخابات في الولايه لصالحه او بالنسبه
للفساد المالي في مؤسسه ترامب او حتى في
احداث الكابتل او حتى الوثائق السريه التي
عثر عليها فيما لارجو اذا الرئيس بغض
النظر عن كل هذه الاتهامات سيحاول ان
يستفيد منها
الان يتربع على القمه في الحزب الجمهوري
لكن هل هذا سيساعده في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه هذا هو السؤال طبعا يكون هو مرشح
الجمهوريين وهناك تاييد واسع له لكن لا
نعرف هذا اذا تمت ام لا لكن مشكله مع باقي
الامريكيين مع الذين يعتقدون ثلثيهم
يعتقدون بانه يجب ان يواجه القضاء الاكيد
باني ساعود لك سنبقى مع هذه الصور
المباشره لموكب ترامب الى حين وصوله الى
المحكمه اذهب الى واشنطن معك في الواقع
اليوم كانت هناك تصريحات
عديده من جمهوريين وديمقراطيين في اخر هذه
التصريحات السيناتور الجمهوريه يقال بانه
سنندم على اليوم الذي مثل فيه ترامب امام
المحكمه طويلا الى اي مدى هذا الموقف الذي
فيه ترامب اليوم قد يشنج الجمهوريين وقد
يمثل او قد يؤثر على داخل الحزب الجمهوري
حتى الان تبدو المبادره بيد الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب فهو يريد ان يكون مرشح الحزب
الجمهوري يريد ان يصبح الرئيس مره ثانيه
في العام 2025 كل ما يحدث الان يعطيه كل
الانتباه من قبل الجمهور الامريكي يحاول
ان يستغل هذه اللحظات السلبيه جدا لمصلحته
وهو يتقدم ايضا على باقي المرشحين في
الحزب الجمهوري وصول المبادره الى يد
الرئيس السابق
تمكنه من خطف الاضواء كلها هذا يعني انها
تاتي على حساب مرشحين اخرين وهذا يثبت
ايضا النظريه التي يلقيها ترامب ومؤيد من
ان الحزب الديمقراطي يستعمل العداله
لاغراض سياسيه الكلام الذي يقوله
السيناتور من ممكن جدا ان يكون صحيحا هناك
تاييد ايضا لهذه المقاربه من ان
الديمقراطيين يستغلون العداله لاغراض
سياسيه وهذا ما قاله ايضا رئيس مجلس
النواب مكارثي هناك اشخاص كثيرين في الحزب
الجمهوري يريدون تخطي ترامب ولكن حتى الان
هم لم يتمكنوا من ذلك طيب ريتا انت من
امام الكونجرس وفي الواقع هذه التطورات او
هذا الملف استذكرنا من خلاله كذلك واقعه
السياحه الكونجرس
هل يمكن ان نجد انفسنا في نفس الاطار
بمعنى انه سيكون هناك حشد لمؤيد ترامب ولو
انه في الساعات القليله الماضيه هم حاضرون
فقط بالعشرات لا اكثر ليست هناك حشود
كبيره ولكن بحسب متابعاتك هل يمكن ان
يتغير هذا الوضع
اليوم من الصعب خاصه مع
اتحاد الجمهوريين وراء ترامب في هذه
القضيه تحديدا ولكن دائما كانت تجديد على
انه يجب عدم اللجوء الى العنف والتظاهرات
العنيفه في الشارع كل الجمهوريين اعربوا
عن دعمهم للترامب دعينا نستثني فقط معجون
جرين التي دعت الى تظاهرات في نيويورك
لدعم الرئيس البريء والرئيس الحقيقي
للولايات المتحده ولكن كما ذكرت ناديه
ربما لم يكن هناك حشد كبير لمناصتي ترامب
استمعوا لماجوري جرين وذهبوا الى هناك
المشهد هنا مختلف تماما هناك دائما خوف من
اي استخدام للعنف في اي مظاهرات في الشارع
تدعم ترامب وهذا ما يشدده الجمهوريون ان
كان من رئيس
او حتى من
الشيوخ المحسوبين على الحزب الجمهوري
يصرون بانه لا يجب اللجوء على العنف
وطبعا يجب دعم ترامب حتى وسائل الاعلام
المحسوبه على الحزب الجمهوري ريم كانت
بهذا الاطار الكل نسي خلافاته مع ترامب
ولكن استمروا في دعمه ولكن دائما باستخدام
تعابير
لا يمكن استخدامها ضدهم في المستقبل بانه
هم حرضوا على اي عنف في الشارع طيب ناديه
منذ قليل محامي ترامب جدد التاكيد وقال
بان موكله اي دونالد ترامب سيرفض
الاتهامات التي سنبقى في انتظارها طبعا
ستنشر بطريقه رسميه
ليطلع عليها الكل ولكن المحامي يقول بان
دونالد ترامبس يرفض الاتهامات وسنطالب
بنقل المحاكمه هذا اليقين الذي يتحدث به
المحامي يضعنا في اطار امكانيه حقيقيه
لنقل هذه المحاكمات تعتقدين
ريم لمن سؤال نجا لك سؤال طبعا كنا نتحدث
عن محامي ترامب تستمعين لي الان
سمعت سمعت السؤال لا اسمع السؤال انه عدد
المراس على فكره قبل قليل بالفعل قال
محامي الرئيس ترامب بانه يريد ان ينقل
المحاكمه من من هاتم من هنا الى
وهي قريبه جدا من منهات لكنه يعتبر بان في
مناطق بالتحديد هناك تصويت بواحد بالمئه
فقط لصالح الجمهوريين وبالتالي هو يرى بان
المحاكمه لن تكون عادله ستكون منحازه ايضا
هاجم القاضي وقال بان ابنه القاضي عملت مع
كامله هاريس وهي نائبه الرئيس وقال بانهم
يعادون عائله ترامب وترام
اليوم الاول والرئيس يهاجمه لذا سيطلب
محامو الرئيس بنقل المحاكمه الى ستاتين
كنا نتحدث في النشاط السابقه بانه يريد ان
ينقلها الى ولايه اخرى قانونيه لا اعرف
اذا كان هذا ام لا لكن الان نعرف بانه
يريد ان ينقلها في داخل نيويورك لكن الى
منطقه اخرى يعتقد ترامب بانها ستكون اكثر
انصافا في حقه لكن على كل الاحوال هذا
يعتمد على القاضي ويعتمد على الاجراءات
القانونيه اذا كان بالفعل باستطاعه الرئيس
ترامب ومحاميه ان يثبتوا بانه لن يتلقى
محاكمه عادله لكن
سنرى لاحقا ما هي هذه الاتهامات وهل
بالفعل ستستمر هذه المحاكمه ام لا هل احد
هذه التهم ترقى الى الجنايه ستوجه اليه
اتهامات اقوى من ذلك هل سترتبط بتحقيقات
اخرى هذا كله طي الكتمان وسنرى الان ماذا
يحدث خلال
اقول ربما الدقائق وليس الساعات المسافه
ما بين برج ترامب وهنا في المحكمه في
لورمان هاتن ليست ببعيده وبالتالي
الاجراءات الامنيه خلفي كما راينا قبل
قليل الوجود المكثف لرجال الشرطه الذين
بداوا يصفون رجل الى جانب رجل يعني وكانه
لا يوجد هناك امكانيه لشخص ان يخترق حتى
الصف لا نتحدث فقط عن الحواجز الاسمنتيه
والحديديه لكن نتحدث عن وجود الشرطه التي
لن تسمح باي عمل عرف على فكره هناك تحذير
من عمده نيويورك ومن رئيس الشرطه بان اي
شخص يقل بالامن سيتم اعتقاله على الفوز
صحيح نحن نتابع كل هذه التفاصيل نتابع هذه
الصوره كذلك المباشره والحيه لموكب ترامب
وهو بعد خروجه طبعا من برجه وهو في طريقه
الى المحكمه محكمه منهاتن وعيننا كذلك على
اخر
واخر العواجل ناديه في اخر التصريحات رئيس
اللجنه القضائيه بمجلس النواب يقول بان اي
قرار بحذر النشر في قضيه ترامب غير دستوري
نتحدث عن مخاوف من حظر النشر فيما يخص
لوائح الاتهامات او هناك جزئيات اخرى من
جلسه المحاكمه قادره ان تنشر
عفوا هناك ضجه حولي ارجو اعاده السؤال لو
سمحتي ريم طيب رئيس اللجنه القضائيه بمجلس
النواب يقول بان اي قرار بحذر النشر في
قضيه راب غير دستوري هو
يتخوف من ان يكون هناك قرار بحذر النشر
فسالت ان كان حظر النشر يخص فقط لائحه
الاتهامات ام ان هناك تفاصيل اخرى للجلسه
يمكن ان يحضر نشرها
لا اعتقد اعتقد انه يتحدث عن لائحه
الاتهام وهي لائحه طويله اذا تحدثنا عن 33
اتهاما او ما شابه هذا نتحدث عن صفحات
كبيره جدا وطويله من الاتهامات لكن ربما
ايضا في داخل المحكمه يعني الصور الان
ستكون بمتناول الجميع لانه بالبدايه كنا
نقول بانه قد لا يستطيع تستطيع الكاميرات
ان تلتقط صوره للرئيس ترامب في داخل
المحكمه الان نعرف بانه سيكون هناك صور
لكنها ليست بفيديو هي صور فوتوغرافيه
وبالتالي اعتقد بانه هو يتحدث بشكل عام
طبعا سيكون هناك الكثير من النقاط المثيره
للجدل قانونيا واعلاميا واتهامات من قبل
فريق المحامين وطاقم الدفاع عن الرئيس
ترامب اسمع الان على فكره طائرات مروحيه
بالقرب من المحكمه هذا يعني بان ربما
هناك اجراءات امنيه على كل المستويات
بالفعل على الارض وعلى الجو وعلى المنافذ
البحريه والاخيره تخوفا لاي احتراز يعني
اليوم بالتحديد لانه ايضا يوم تاريخي
وهناك تعلم للدروس بما حدث في واشنطن في
اقتحام ابناء الكونغرس لا احد يريد ان
يترك ولا يعني
تفصيل هامش ولو كانت صغير جدا جدا
وبالتالي هما ياخذون كل هذه الاجراءات صوت
المروحيات تقترب منا نسمعها ربما بشكل
افضل الان هذا يعني بالفعل بانه اريد ان
انظر خلفي قليلا لو كان في لا اعرف اذا
كان في امكانيه ان ناخذ اربعه اربع صناديق
وليس فقط
الموكب الرئيس لانه عندنا ايضا نستطيع ان
نرفض الحركه هنا طيب خلينا ناخذ الصوره
الرجال الشرطه صحيح ناخذ معك صوره نا الى
اننا نتابع نتابع هذه الصوره وصول ترامب
تفضلي
اذا هذا هذه لحظات وصول الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب هو يقترب من محيط
المحكمه هناك حضور امني وهناك حضور اعلامي
مكثف لمتابعه هذه التفاصيل نحن نتابع على
الجانب الايسر من الشاشه تصوير بواسطه
المروحيات التي تتابع كذلك اصول الرئيس
ترامب وفي نشرات سابقه ناديه كنت اكدت على
ان ترامب يدخل من الباب الخلفي ولكن ماذا
هذه هي الصوره التي تبين وصول الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب نبقى مع هذه الصوره
صوره واضحه نحن نتابعه الان هو خرج من
السياره والان في طريقه الى دخول محكمه من
حاتم يدخل فعلا الى محكمه من هاتن حيث
سيقف امام القاضي وسيستمع الى لائحه
الاتهامات نحن نتابع دائما هذه الصور
واعود لك ناديه كنت تحدثت عن بعض
الجزئيات او تفاصيل الخاصه بهذه الجلسه هل
نستذكرها كيف ستكون هذه الجلسه طالما هي
ليست مصوره يمنع التصوير بالفيديو داخل
هذه الجلسه ولكن ما الذي قيل بخصوص
الاجراءات التي ستحدث داخل قاعه المحكمه
ما نعرفه حتى الان اولا اريد ان اصف نوعا
ما هذه الصوره التي هذه الصور خاصه
بالعربيه نحن نقف الان امام المحكمه ونرى
رجال الشرطه ونرى المروحيه وهي الان
بالتحديد يا فوق
المحكمه تماما فوق المحكمه الرئيس سياتي
سيدخل مع محاميه سيكون هناك شخص في داخل
المحكمه هو الذي سيستقبله هذا الشخص هو
شرطي يعني لكنه لا يلبس الزيئه الرسمي
لكنه سيكون مسلح الان الشرطه حتى تمنع
دخول بعض الماره بالقرب من المحكمه الان
نراهم سيدخل الرئيس سيتم اخذ بصماته
لا نعرف متى سيتحدث على الاقل ما محاموه
قالوا بانه سيتحدث لكن لا نعرف اذا كان
سيتحدث بالخارج او في الداخل لنعرف اذا
حتى هذا المدخل الذي نراه الان على شاشه
العربيه بصور ح لنا ونحن ناخذها الان هل
سيدخل من هذا المدخل ام انه هناك مدخل اخر
كما عرفنا ساعات الصباح بان هناك
فقط لانه لدي صحيح ولكن ناديه فقط للتوضيح
لدينا صورتان هناك صوره تنقلها قناه
العربيه وهي صور حصريه ولكن هناك صوره
اخرى وتابعنا خروج تراب من السياره
ودخوله من مدخل اخر ربما جهز لهذا الغرض
بعيدا عن كاميرات الاعلام لاحظنا دخول
وفيما بعد قلت بانه سيكون هناك فريق شرطي
في استقباله سيتم تصويره وفيما بعد ما
الذي سيحدث
بعد ذلك
سيدخل الى القاعه التي سيكون فيها القاضي
والقاضي سيقوم بفتح هذا الملف او الظرف
الذي يحتوي على لائحه الاتهامات التي قلنا
على مدى يومين بانها تزيد عن 30 اتهاما
سيقراها ويقول للرئيس هل انت مذنب ام انك
غير مذنب طبعا كما نعرف وكما قال الرئيس
نفسه ترامب اخبرنا بانه سيقول بانه غير
مذنب لا نريد ان نقول بانه لا يعترف
بشرعيه المحكمه هذه في حد ذاتها تعتبر
احتقار للمحكمه لكنه يرى غير عادله
وبالتالي لماذا الان لماذا هذا التوقيت
نحن نعرف بان هذه القضيه بدات في عام 2016
الى اخره وبالتالي سيقول بانها مسيسه لن
يقول هذا للقاضي ويقوله وسيحتفظ ربما فيه
الليله عندما يتحدث من مره لارجو من مسكنه
في ولايه فلوريدا لكن حتى بعض محامين
ينصحون وبعدم الحديث لانه عاده في
المحاكمات وفي القضايا ومن هنا البيت
الابيض يلتزم الصمت ليس فقط لانه في صالح
الرئيس بايدن لا يتحدث لكن عاده عندما
تكون هناك يعني امور قضائيه او قضيه
مفتوحه لا تزال مفتوحه سواء كانت وزاره
العدل التي تحقق او ان الامر وصل الى
محكمه في العاده لا سياسي يتحدث لا يتدخل
فيها فالبادر بانه قد لا يكون في مصلحه
الرئيس لكن الرئيس كما تعرفينه هو ترامب
وهو يستمع الى نفسه وهو الذي يقرر اذا كان
هذا في مصلحته ام لا لكن هو في النهايه
انه يريد ان يتوجه الى مؤيدي هو يقول بانه
يدافع عنهم بانه يقف الان امام العداله من
اجلهم وبالتالي يجعل هذه القضيه وكانها
قضيه
للقاعده الشعبيه له ليس قضيه فرديه ليس هو
الذي يتهم بدفع اموال لممثله بل هو يدافع
عن منطق العداله ويقول بان هذه محكمه هي
محكمه كانجرو ايانها تشابه دول محاكم دول
العالم الثالث وهاجم القاضي والمدع العام
وقال بانهم قريبين من الديمقراطيين والى
اخره وطلب طبعا بنقل المحكمه من منهج الى
صحيح ونحن نتحدث ناديه الان عن سينان
ترامب اصبح
رهن الاعتقال الى حين مثوله امام القاضي
يعني منذ دخوله من بوابه المحكمه هو يعتبر
معتقل حتى يمثل امام القاضي ليتلو عليه
الاخير لائحه الاتهامات الرسميه ولكن نادي
البعض يقول بان الملفت ليس هناك حضور
لحشود كبيره لمؤيدي ترامب بمعنى انهم لا
يتجاوزون العشرات وهذا ما كنت اكدتيه في
نشرات سابقه هل هناك ثقه من ترامب ومن
فريقه فريق الدفاعه بانه ستتم تبرئه ام
هناك تو بعدم الحشد حتى لا تتوتر الامور
اكثر
يعني بالفعل شيء ملفت ان نرى بانه الرئيس
نفسه الذي اعلن للعالم اخبرنا بان محاكمه
ستكون يوم الثلاثاء وقال بان هناك تسريب
من داخل المحكمه بانه سيواجه القضاء لكن
كان قد قبل اسبوعين هذا هذا التصريح لكن
بالفعل تم هو يوم الثلاثاء على كل الاحوال
كان الرئيس طلب من مؤيديه ان يتجمعوا من
مناصريه ان يتجمعوا لكن لم نرى الاستجابه
بهذا الشكل ربما نيويورك لديها خاصيه
بانها ولايه ديمقراطيه بان هناك انقسام
بالفعل حزبي بانه الديمقراطيين متشددين
هنا وبعض جزء منهم يعني يهاجم حتى الاعلام
الموالي للجمهوريه مثل محطه فوكس كما رايت
بالامس في شوارع نيويورك لكن ايضا جزء منه
هو اختلاف القضيه يعني هذا تحقيق
بدفع رئيس يعني في حد
بانه هذه السابقه تاريخيه وما تحدثت عنه
قبل قليل ريم بانه يعتقل الان الرئيس
ترامب معتقل يعني هذه الكلمه
غريبه في التاريخ الامريكي ان نقول بان
رئيس اعتقل وهو قيد الاعتقال الان لكن
الرئيس سلم على فكره لو لم يستجب الرئيس
ولم ياتي بقدميه من خلال هذا الموكب
الكبير كان بامكان الشرطه ان تذهب الى
مكان تواجده ويتم اعتقاله ويتم وضع القيود
في يديه لكن هذا لم يتم لانه الرئيس
استجاب وقرر ان ياتي بقدميه الى المحكمه
وبالتالي هو الان رهن الاعتقاد لكن قضيته
هو دفع اموال لممثله اباحيه وعلى فكره
ربما في هذه التهم ايضا هناك حديث عن
ممثله اخرى اسمها كريم ماكدونالدز
هي ايضا تم دفع اموالها وهذه الاموال كلها
التي تدور حول ترامب هو دخول هذه الاموال
ضمن انتهاكات القواعد الانتخابيه
الامريكيه الى اخره نحن لا نتحدث عن قضيه
عاديه بان الرئيس السابق اقام علاقه غير
شرعيه خارج اطار الزواج الى اخره سنتحدث
عن هذه الاموال كيف دفعت وكيف الرئيس زور
اموالا يقول بانها هي خدمات قانونيه
لمايكل
المحامي الذي سيكون هو الشاهد الاهم في
هذه القضيه والذي طبعا انقلب ضد الرئيس
ترامب بعد ان دفع 130 الف دولار لهذه
الممثله بعدما كان ابرز داعيه وسجن حتى من
اجله ساعود لك بعد لحظات ناديه ربما
نستكمل بعض هذه صوره ترامب اذا هذه صوره
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب بعد دخوله من
مدخل المحكمه محكمه منهاتن وهذه هي الصوره
الوحيده ربما لترامب وهو يرفع يده وكانه
فائز او منتصر على الاقل من خلال هذه
الصوره يرفع يده في محاوله لتبيان انتصاره
وصموده في هذه القضيه ساعود لك بعد
قليل استضيف من واشنطن ستيفن فرانسوس
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه ماريسي
ستيفن اهلا بك معنا
كيف يمكن توصيف ما يحدث الان في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بمعنى هل هي
الديمقراطيه وهو تطبيق للديمقراطيه
بحذافيرها ام ان هناك تشفي سياسي كما يقول
مؤيد ترامب
كل شيء لابد لنا ان نؤمن بالولايات
المتحده وبدول
اخرى في الغرب بانه ما من شخص يجب ان يكون
فوق القانون والمساله متروكه لاجراءات
المحكمه لتقرر مدى براءه او جرمي الرئيس
السابق ترامب حقيقه الامر في هذا الواقع
بانه سوف يعامل حاله حال مواطن امريكي
عديل ولن نشهد في التاريخ الامريكي وجود
رئيسا يخضع لقاعه محكمه جنائيه ويتم مثله
امامها
تقول بان ترامب معتقل منذ قليل كنا تحدثنا
عن هذا الموضوع بما انه سلم نفسه بنفسه
ولكن الى اي مدى الاعلام الامريكي اليوم
يصر على طرح مثل هكذا توصفات خاصه بترامب
بالقول بانه معتقل وحضرتك تعلم بان هذا
ربما اول توصيف او اول صفه تلصق
برئيس سابق والموضوع قادر ان يكون حساس
نعم هذه قضيه حساسه للغايه نستطيع ان نرى
من خلال استطلاعات الراي في انحاء العالم
بان هناك اعداد كبيره من الامريكيين الذين
يعتقدون بان الرئيس الامريكي يجب ان يخضع
للقانون حاله الاخرين وهناك استطلاعات
الراي اخرى تقول بان الرئيس قد عمل بطريقه
غير منصفه او غير عادله ولم يخطئ في هذه
الجرائم الموسيوبه الي هذا جزء من العمليه
القانونيه لاثبات البراءه او الجرم هناك
ادله سوف تقدم في المحكمه المفتوحه وفقا
للاجراءات المعمول بها ما زلنا في بدايه
هذه الاجراءات القانونيه ولم نقترب ابدا
من اي قرار باي شكل من الاشكال
ايا كانت النتيجه سواء البراءه او الادانه
ولكن مجرد مذاب متابعه هذه التفاصيل الى
اي مدى قادره ان تؤثر على حياته السياسيه
المستقبليه بحسب قراءتك صيد السفن
تظهر ان اعدادا كبيرا من الجمهوريين سوف
يعملون بالتصويت في في
الاجراءات او
في التحضيرات التمهيديه بان هناك تصويت
لعدد كبير من المرشحين لكن لم تتغير
استطاعت الرئيس بالنسبه
للمؤيدين الرئيس السابق المشكله الكبرى
للجمهوريين بصوره عامه هي الانتخابات
عندما يكون احد المرشحين الجمهوريين يواجه
نظيره الديمقراطي هذه سوف تكون هي الحاله
التي سوف يواجهها فيها ترامب الذي يقول
فيه بانه انه قد وجود شخصا بدون اي مشاكل
قانونيه قد يكون الخير الاقدار وهذا الامر
كان جليا بالنسبه للديمقراطيين هذه
المساله سيئه بالنسبه لقدره ترامب للتواصل
مع الناخبين الذين
يرون بانه ما من حزب حتى اللحظه يشكل
الاغلبيه في هذه الانتخابات المقبله سيد
سيفنت تفضل بالبقاء معي اشير فقط الى بعض
هذه الصور كنا او ردنا منذ قليل صوره من
بينها ترامب يرفع يده من امام بوابه
المحكمه هناك صور اخرى في نفس هذا الاطار
مع نفس هذه الرمزيه وكانها يتحدث عن صموده
وعن اتجاهه لمواجهه هذه الاتهامات هنا
خروجه من السياره وهنا كذلك بعض اسوار
الاخرى وهو واقف من امام مدخل المحكمه سيد
ستيفن هناك تكاتف من الجمهوريين بخصوص هذه
القضيه ولكن هل تعتقد بان هذا التكاثف
سيقتصر فقط على بدايه هذه الاجراءات الى
حين وضوح الصوره ام ان الحزب الجمهوري
سيسان ترامب الى درجه امكانيه طرح كمرشح
رسمي للانتخابات القادمه
المساله التي يجب علينا ان ننتظر ان نراها
في الاسابيع القادمه هناك بعض الجمهوريين
الذين قدموا ترشيحاتهم والبعض الاخر قد
يتقدم لسباق الرئاسي سوف يكون هناك عدد
كبير من الجمهورين الذين سوف يتقدمون
للترشح للرئاسه ضد ترشح ترامب الذي يرون
بانه قد لا يمتلك تلك
المسؤوليه وفي وجه الصعوبات القانونيه
التي يواجهها سوف تكون استراتيجيه ذات
مخاطر كبيره للجمهوريين الاستمرار في دعم
سترام بالطريقه التي نراها في هذه المرحله
سوف يكون هناك خطا جوهريا بالنسبه
للجمهورين
للعمل على ولكن لابد لهم الاطاحه بجو
بايدن في عام 2004 لكن لابد من وجود
المرشح قوي لمواجهه بايدن
هل تعتقد بان هذه المحاكمه ونحن تابع
بدايه اجراءات هذه المحاكمه الى حين
الوقوف على لائحه الاتهامات الرسميه وفيما
بعد سنتابع مختلف الاجراءات ولكن هل تعتقد
بان هذه المحاكمه سيكون ما قبلها وما
بعدها فعليا ام ان هناك مبالغه في القول
بذلك
اعتقد انه من الاشياء التي يجب ان نثمنها
بالنظام القانوني الامريكي بانه بطيء
ومتثقل للخطى لذا لن يحدث الكثير من حيث
التطورات التي قد تحدث بالمقارنه ما يجري
اليوم اليوم في جلسه المحكمه سوف يتم
تلاوه لائحه الاتهامات التي لا تزال قيد
سريه الامر قد يتعلق بدفعات قدمت
والاتهامات او مزاعم
بتقديمي افادات مزوره وبعض المستندات
المزيفه فيما يتعلق بتمويل حملته
الانتخابيه واستخدام تلك الاموال من
حسابات ترامب هناك بعض القضايا والمشاكل
القانونيه فضلا عن غيرها
بالاضافه الى قروض ترامب الاخرى
ما يتعلق بمسائل المصرفيه لا نعلم ما هي
طبيعتي تلك اللائحه وما الذي سوف يقدمه
المدعي العام في مواجهه لذا سوف تكون هناك
مداولات مطوله وهناك اوجه قوه واوجه ضعف
لهذه القضيه لكن المساله الاكثر اهميه
بشان التحديات القانونيه التي واجهت رمز
بان هذه فقط خطوه واحده من جمله اتهامات
يواجهها وهناك قضايا اخرى
متعلقه بجورجيا حيث ينظر الادعاء العام
هناك الى
بعض
المحادثات الهاتفيه التي تحدث بها الى
المسؤولين في جورجيا لقلب نتيجه
الانتخابات التي فاز بها بايدن في تلك
الولايه وهناك ايضا عمليات التحقيق
فيدراليه تتطلب تتعلق بمسائل بوثائق سريه
التي قام بتخزينها في منزله الخاص وكذلك
احتماليه تورط ترامب باعمال العصيان التي
حدثت في السادس من يناير
نعم اجل عن مراسل العربيه ترامب طلب ان
يتم التقاط صوره جنائيه له خلال اعتقاله
اذا كما نتابع اسفل الشاشه مع هذه الصور
التي نشرت لتراب عند دخوله الى محكمه من
هاته ترامب طلب ان يتم التقاط صوره جنائيه
له خلال اعتقال هذا العاجل ياتي بعد خبر
اخر كان هناك حديث عن انه لن تلتقت صوره
لها عن مصادر لفوكسنيوز تقول بانه مدعي
عاما هاتا كان قال سابقا بانه لن يطلب ان
يتم تصوير التراب لن يطلب منه صوره جنائيه
لتراب ولكن في اخر الاخبار ترامب نفسه طلب
ان يتم التقاط صوره له وهنا ان كانت ناديه
تسمعني من محيط المحكمه ناديه ان كنت معنا
نحن نتابع هذه الصور ونتابع كذلك هذا
العاجل اسفل الشاشه ترامب هو نفسه
ان يتم التقاطه
ان يتم اخذ صوره جنائيه له خلينا نفهم
قليلا ما المراد من ذلك
المراد من هذا ريم هو جمع اموال الرئيس
سيستخدم هذه الصوره ليقول بانه ضحيه
لنظام قضائي فاسد وغير عادل وانه يعامله
كالمجرمين وبالتالي هذه الصوره تساوي الف
دولار ان لم يكن مليون دولار فبالتالي هو
كما تحدثنا على مدى نشرات الطويله وهات
بهذه التغطيه بان الرئيس هو سيد الاستفاده
من كل الازمات وهو يعرف تماما كيف يوظف
الاعلام كيف يوظف
الفرص لصالحه ويستغل كل نقاط الضعف من قبل
اعدائه وخصومه والان يقول بانه مواطن عادي
مثل باقي الامريكيين وهو ليس فوق القانون
وبالتالي يريد ان يعامل مثل البقيه
وسيستخدم هذه الصوره لطبعا لتجنيد مؤيدين
جدد له ولجماعه تبرعات منه ولكن ايضا ما
كان ملفت وانا لم ارى الصور على فكره لكن
قبل قليل ساصفها لك
اسمحي لي فقط رايتها قبل قليل
ننتقل الى البيت الابيض طيب خليك معي
ناديه ساعود لك بعد قليل مباشره الى البيت
الابيض ننتقل يبدو بان هناك فعلا كلمه
المتحدث الرسمي باسم بيت الابيض المتحدث
فان السماء
لضمان مقاربه حكومه فيدراليه بالنسبه
للمخاطر او الفرص ونعتقد والرئيس يعتقد ان
الشركات التكنولوجيه مسؤوله عن منتجاتها
وانها امنه للاستخدام من قبل عامه الناس
هذه مساله نؤمن وهو كما ذكرتم فسوف يتم
التوجه الى الكونجرس
وسوف تسمعون من منه بصوره مباشره حول
ضروره هذه المنتجات التكنولوجيه وسلامتها
حول بعض القضايا الاقتصاديه التي ذكرتيها
كانت هذه كلمه تشمل العديد من الملفات
تحدثه الا
بيض كان هناك سؤال عن محاكمه ترامبورت
الابيض قال لن نعلق على اي جانب مرتبط
بقضيه ترامب بطريقه واضحه صريحه مختصره
واعود لك ناديه من جديد كنا نتحدث عن صور
ترامب رافي عن قبضته من جهه ومن جهه اخرى
رافعا سلامه وكنت تودين التعليق على هذه
الصور تفضل لناديه
كنت اقول بانه ربما التلويح هو عادي لكن
القبضه هي ملفته للنظر لانها شعار
الديمقراطيه شعار الراديكاليين شعار
الثوريين عاده الامريكيين من اصول افريقيه
سوى كانت حركه
حقوق المدنيه الفهود السود ماتلوثر وغيرهم
وخصوصا الامريكيين من اصول افريقيه هم
الذين يقومون برفع يديهم بشكل قبضه وكانهم
يتحدثون النظام فغريب جدا في الواقع ان
نرى الرئيس عاده الانجلوس او البيض لا
يستخدمونها هم الاقليات او الذين يشعرون
بظلم كبير ظلم تاريخي ضدهم بشكل عام هم
الذين يستخدمون سواء كان بالولايات
المتحده او في دول العالم الثالث هي رمز
مواجهه الاستبداد اذا اردتي فهذا يعني بان
الرئيس طبعا يعتبر بانه مظلوم بانه الضحيه
الى اخره وهذه الصوره بهذه القبضه كما
رايناها قبل قليل ستكون ايفون يعني ستكون
ايقونه نوعا ما سيستخدمها الرئيس دون ادنى
شك في كل مناسبه وطبعا اهم شيء بالنسبه له
هو التاييد للانتخابات القادمه سواء كان
بالاصوات او بالاموال لحمله الانتخابيه
طيب تفضلي بالبقائي معي ناديه بالبيسي
اعود لك بعد قليل هذه مشاهدينا الصور من
داخل المحكمه
وهناك اخبار عن انه طبعا اوردتها وسائل
الاعلام الامريكيه عن ان ترامب يعد
كانه معتقل او معتقل هكذا وصفاته على
الاقل سينان هو معتقل الى حين مثوله امام
القاضي ومن ثم يجب ان يدفع او تدفع كفاله
حتى يخرج نحن في متابعه خاصه لكل هذه
التطورات ولكل هذه التفاصيل لحظه لحظه
مشاهدينا وهذه صوره الاولى من خارج
المحكمه او من محيط المحكمه بعض المؤيدين
لترامب يرفعون شعارات ويرفعون بعض
اللافتات في الواقع عددهم لا يتخطى
العشرات كما افادتنا منذ قليل نجرب البيت
مجرد مكتب العربيه في واشنطن ومن الجانب
الايمن من الشاشه هناك صور كذلك من داخل
المحكمه كنا منذ قليل تبعنا دخول ترامب
كنا تبعنا قبل ذلك خروجه من برج ترامب كيف
اتجه عبر الطريق طبعا موكب كان
مشدد التامين الى حين وصوله وعند الوصول
كان من اللافت انه رفع قبضه قبضه لا نعلم
المنتصر
المظلوم كما قالت ناديه بلبيسي منذ قليل
ولكن هذه هي القبضه التي
لفتت كثيرين على كل
سنتابع كل هذا بعد قليل ولكن ينضم لنا في
هذه التغطيه تم حرب رئيس التحالف
الامريكيه الشرق الاوسط صيد الديمقراطيه
سيتم اهلا بك معنا نحن نتابع كل هذه
التفاصيل ودخول ترامب وصوره وكذلك حتى
طلبه بان يتم اخذ صوره جنائيه له استوقفت
البعض حضرتك كيف قرات كل هذه الجزئيات
يعني اول مرحله لك والمشاهدين اهلا طبعا
هذا النهار غير اعتيادي هذه اليوم بالفعل
في الصين نحن جمهوريه الموز نحن كاوليات
متحده لا يحق لنا بالتمديد والشك
بانتخابات في دول اخرى مثل فنزويلا اما
اما بالروسيه اما غير ذلك اما بالنسبه
للرئيس ترامب
لماذا تستغرب ذلك لماذا لا يحدث ذلك في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لماذا تقارن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بما يحدث مثلا
في فنزويلا من ديكتاتوريه اليس هذا هو
القانون اليس هذا هو تطبيق للقانون
سؤال سؤال جيد ولكن قبل منه الرئيس اندفع
غرامي 850 الف دولار
بالتسعينات وكان في بثلاثه اتهامات جنائيه
ضده ضد الكونغرس ضد المحكمه وضد الشعب
ولكن السياسيين في ذلك الوقت اعتبروا انه
مستوى الديمقراطيه في الولايات المتحده
ورئيس الجمهوريه يجب ان نحافظ عليها ولا
نصبح مثل الجمهوريات الموز الرئيس اوباما
دفع 250 الف دولار غرامي باشكالات
بالانتخابات السيده اندفعت 500 الف دولار
بالغش اللي عملته بموضوع مع كل ولكن
القيمين على الوضع الامريكي ووزاره العدل
قرروا انه ما يحاكموا لانه ثمن صفه مثل
الجمهوريات الموز واذ نتفاجا بعد 2030 سنه
من حادثه اليوم بالفعل صفينا مثل جمهوريات
الموز بامريكا الوسطى ولا يحق لنا
[موسيقى]
كثيره وخاصه بولايات بكره راح يرفعوا
دعاوى ضد ضد هانتر بايدن راح يدفعوا دعاوى
ضد جو بايدن وكل من يوصل لسده الرئاسه من
بعد ما يتخلص وكنا بغنى عنها وخاصه هذه
الحادثه بالذات هذا الحاتم مع هذه لا اسمح
لي فقط على تعليق البعض يقول بانه رغم كل
ما ذكرته من اعتقاد للمظلوميه الى اخره
ولكن ترامب يستغل هذه القضيه يستغلها
سياسيا يستغلها شعبيا ويستغلها ماليا
كثيرا
النتيجه اجبره على استغلالها وهو معروف
عنه انه شخص امبيتياز شخص قوي جبار يقف ضد
هذه الهجمات ولا ينحني لانه يعتبر القضيه
ليست ضد ترامب وانما هي ضد المجتمع
الامريكاني اليوم لما الامريكان عملوا
غلطه بالثمانينات على ايام رونالد ريجن
اسقط النظام الشيوعي والعدسات النظام
الشيوعي الايديولوجي شيوعيه ارض خصبه في
الولايات المتحده وهي اليوم تتغلغل فيها
وبالفعل ابتدت مع بقوه مع الرئيس السابق
اوباما استغلها هو وطورها اكثر ولكن بدنا
نرجع للسؤال بالذات نسال قبل قبل السؤال
اعلم سيتهم حضرتك من اكبر المؤيدين لرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب وهذا لاحظناه في اكثر
من نشره واكثر من حضور معنا ولكن ان تقول
بان المستهدف هو الشعب الامريكي
هناك مبالغه ام لا المستهدف هو ترامب حتى
ان البعض قال بانه ليس الحزب الجمهوري من
هو مستهدف ولكن تراب كشخص مستهدف من خلال
هكذا قضيه
لماذا لانه اول ما وصل على الدوله العميقه
هو ضد الحروبات في العالم هو مع قوى
تجاريه قويه في العالم وهذا لا يخدم
النظام العالمي هو رجع القوميه الوطنيه
لامريكا وقال الرئيس بايدن منذ منذ عده
ايام نحن سنحاكم الرئيس ترامب حتى ما لا
يستطيع ان يصل الى شده الحكم مره ثانيه
ليش لانه في مدرستايل مدرسه القوميه
الوطنيه ومدرسه الدوله العولويه الغيه ككل
كيان العالم كلها وهذا هو هو الرئيس ترامب
يقف ضد هذه العولمه والاتجاه اليساري
لراجعين يستعملوه من بعد ما سقطت الدوله
الشيوعيه اليوم باليسار الامريكاني
واليسار الدولي يحاول استغلاله لكن مثلا
رئيس بايدن كي تتعامل مع الشرق الاوسط بدو
يحاكم ولي العهد محمد بن سلمان شو عمل ولي
العهد راح على روسيا راح اليوم على الصين
عن يعمل لمصلحه السعوديه والبرازيل عن
يعمل لمصلحه البرازيل فرنسا عم تعمل مع
لمصلحه البرازيل وكلن رايحين على الصين
نحن بامريكا شو عم نعمل ملتهيين كيف بدنا
نحاكم السيد ترامب بحيث لها 17 سنه هذه
الحادثه صارت بال 2006 مع هذه السيده وهذه
السيده استغلت
دفع الاموال صار هناك حديث بانه شاكين على
الاقل دفعوا ترامب موجود داخل البيت
الابيض في 2016 مش 2016 2016 كانت هناك
بدايه لجمع الدلائل الموضوع
وتراب موجود على راس
الرئاسه الامريكيه
صحيح ولكن المحكمه يرفد والوزاره العدل
نظرت بهذا الموضوع اذا كان في مخالفات ولا
ليس هنالك مخالفات مثل ما حصل مع الرئيس
اوباما مثل ما حصل مع السيد
وتنازلوا عن هذا ليس هناك مخالفات محاميه
السابق يقول بانه ترامب استغل اموال
الحملات الانتخابيه ودفع من هذه الاموال
مقابل صمت الممثله الاباحيه
المحامي تبعه هذا اللي يتكلم عنه
هلا كان الحبس لانه صار هو دجال والمحامي
اللي دافع عن هذه المراه كذلك الامر وكان
اليسار
خليني اذكرك بانه انحبس عندما كان يدافع
عن ترامب لم يخبر
ولكن في بعض القضايا كان مدافع عن ترامب
كان مع ترامب
لا الحبس الحبس بالذات لانه تهريب اموال
من شركات خاصه واستغلال سيارات تاكسي هذا
اللي نحبس عليهم منحبس ولانه كذلك انحبس
لانه كذب ودجل قدام الكونغرس الامريكاني
على هذه النقطتين هو ذهب على السجن من ذهب
على السجن لانه بالمشكله هايدي ومحامي هذه
السيده كذلك الامر قبل ما اعطيك كمان
استغل هذه المراه وكمان واشتغل غير ناس
وشرق اموال منها كمان على الحبس هؤلاء
المحاميين اسم منهم دجالين دجالين امام
الراي العام العالمي والمحلي وهذا الذي
حصل بان في نهايه المطبخ اكيد باننا سنبقى
في متابعه كل هذا بالنقاش وبالمزيد كذلك
من المعلومات مع
تطور او مع تقدم الوقت حتى تستكمل الصوره
ساكتفي معك بهذا القدر واشكرك جزيلا الشكر
الاوسط للديمقراطيه نشير مشاهدينا الى هذا
العاجل عن البيت الابيض
قضيه ترامب ليست اولويه بالنسبه اذا البيض
الابيض يعلق ويقول قضيه ترامب ليست اولويه
بالنسبه لبيض وقبل ذلك كانت رفضت المتحدثه
باسم البيت الابيض التعليق على هذه القضيه
قالت بانه لا تعليق عن هذه او على هذه
القضيه والان البيت الابيض يقول بان هذه
القضيه ليست اولويه بالنسبه لبي ساختم هذه
الساعه من محيط محكمه منهاتن معك ناديه
ناديه الصوره ثابته الان نحن نتابع هذه
الصوره من داخل المحكمه هناك تواجد امني
كبير
بايدن ربما ينتظر مثوله لنعلم ان كان وقف
امام القاضي ام لا ولكن الصوره تقول بانه
هناك انتظار
بعض مساعديه وكذلك حتى لفراق امنيه
في انتظار ان يرشح اي شيء او ان يتوضح اي
شيء هل اختلفت صوره من عندك ناديه في هذه
الاسنان
بالخارج لم تختلف في الواقع لا يزال هناك
وجود مكثف لقوات الشرطه بالعكس
يزيد ولا يقل يعني نراهم الان يصطفون في
منتصف الشارع امام المحكمه في الباب
الاساسي كما ذكرنا باننا كنا نتوقع بان
يدخل الرئيس بالباب الخلفي وبالفعل هذا ما
حدث لكن الكل يترقب الان الخطوه القادمه
وهذه الخطوه هي هل الرئيس ترامب سيطلب من
القاضي عندما يقول له الان استطيع ان اتلو
عليك التهم هل تريد ان اقراها علي ام ان
اعطيك اياها يعني مكتوبه عاده في كل
القضايا السابقه حسب ما قرات 90% من
المتهمين عندما يطلب منهم القاضي هذا
الطلب يكتفون فقط بان يحصلوا على هذه
التهم مكتوبه ويتم تسليمها على الفور
للطاقم المحامين وهذا يعتمد يعني مثلا
موضوع الصوره او الماتشوت كنا نتوقع بان
الرئيس ترامب لا يريد ان يقوم بها لكن
بالفعل هكذا هذا الموضوع وقال بانه يريد
ان يكون له صوره في تدخل في هذا السجن لذا
لا نعرف اذا كان القاضي سيقرا التهمه اذا
سيقرا الدوام هذا يعني سيستغرق ربما وقتا
اطول ربما الرئيس ترامب يريد ان يقول بانه
لا يخاف من اي شيء لا يريد ان ان يكون
هناك شيء في السر وبالتالي يريد لكل
الامريكيين ان يسمعوا معا هذه
الاتهامات لكن لا يوجد هناك صور لوسائل
الاعلام والتلفزه تنقل لنا كلمه القاضي
ولا يوجد حتى مصورين الان اذا علينا ان
ننتظر الفتره الزمنيه اذا كان القاضي
سيقرا لوائح الاتهام نعم ونعرف لاحقا ما
هي اللوائح من خلال محاميه الرئيس ام انه
سيكتفي فقط بان يسلمه لوائح الاتهام ويترك
الرئيس ترامب المحكمه باسرع وقت ممكن صحيح
تحدثت عن الصور الصوره الوحيده التي
نتابعها وتنقلها وكالات اعلام دوليه هي
صور من امام قاعه اعتقال ترامب داخل محكمه
منهاتن تبعنا وصوله دخوله الى المحكمه
فيما بعد توجه وطلبه هو بنفسه ان يتم
التقاط صوره جنائيه له وفيما بعد يقف امام
القاضي ليستمع لائحه الاتهامات تحدثت
ناديه سيبقى هذا الباب مفتوح سنتابع من
دخل من هذا الباب يبدو بانه فريق دفع
ترامب سنبقى مع هذه الصور مشاهدينا منذ
قليل ناديه طرحت سؤال ان كانت ترامبسا
يتسلم لائحه الاتهامات مكتوبه ام انه
سيسمح للقاضي بتلاوه هذه الاتهامات بصوت
مرتفع بصوت عالي يعني على كل ننتظر كل هذه
التفاصيل كل هذه الجزئيات هل سيكون الختام
ادانه او تبرئه وكيف سيكون مسار هذه
المحاكمه كيف ستكون التفاصيل وكيف ستكون
التاثيرات على ترامب على الحزب الجمهوري
وكذلك حتى على الداخل الامريكي ساكتفي
بهذا القدر انتهت هذه الساعه ولكن تغطيه
العربيه لا زالت مستمره في متابعه لكل ما
يحدث بالصور بالتفاصيل وكذلك حتى بالعواجل
التي نقراها اسفل الشاشه كيف هي الصوره
بعد قليل مع ميسون نواهز تتسلم البث طبعا
وتنقل لكم كل ما يحدث
[موسيقى]